[Applaudissements]
a
a voil voil
voililevil le
[Musique]
printemp
VO çaen que çamange depuis le ciel s m
au voilà même que mon humeur change DEP
madameido ne sa plus bien où elle habite
fourb dans le B du dos et comme je suis
pasaphrodite je vais pas me tremper les
fesses dans l'eau non faites-moi
danserito lcer faites-moi faites-moi
faites-moi faites-moi faites-moi oublier
faites-moi lcer
allez mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont tous
étendu à pas vouloir danser comme moi à
vouloir péter plus haut que leur cul à
se prendre pour ce qu'ils ne sont pas il
faudrait peut-être leur expliquer que
c'est normal que c'est la nature qu'un
bon homme s fait pour aimer danser à
côté de ses chaussures
[Applaudissements]
a voil
voililil ça reprend tiens voilà que ça
rechatouille je suis comme une bête je
suis comme un fou il a mon cur qui en
vadrouille jeis encore finir sur les
genoux d'autant que c'est là mon décapr
qui va le bien qu'on se déoue et comme
j'ai le goût du sacrifice je vais pas
mourir garde vous faites-moi
danser faites-moi danser faites-moi
faites-moi faites-moi faites-moi oublier
faites-moi danser
ou qu'est-ce que joli les
dames faites-moi faites-moi faites-moi
lancer mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont tous
est tordu à pas vouloir danser comme moi
ceux qui vivent comme des C cousus et
qui meurent comme des pis frois faudrait
peut-être leur expliquer qu'au printemps
c'est dehors que ça se passe et que pour
avoir la bonne santé faut danser à côté
de ces godasses
a
[Musique]
aend faitmo
danser faites-moi danser faites-moi
danser
allez allez allez allez allez allez
allez faites-moi
danser faites-moi danser faites-moi
faites-moi faites-moi fait-moi
faites-moi
[Musique]
oublier